sí
[Música]
ah
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y los acompaño en
este programa para contrastar los puntos
de vista en colombia donde el grupo
guerrillero ejército de liberación
nacional ln aseguró que apoyará un alto
el fuego bilateral que ahora paso a la
retoma de conversaciones de paz esta vez
con el gobierno de izquierdas de gustavo
petro los intentos anteriores de
negociación con lln que cuenta con unos
2400 combatientes y que está acusado de
financiarse a través del narcotráfico la
minería ilegal y el secuestro no han
avanzado en parte por la disidencia
entre sus filas así las cosas cuál es la
expectativa alrededor de los nuevos
diálogos en el marco de la llamada paz
total lo conversaremos en un momento y
para ello nos acompañan iván cepeda
quien es el senador del gobernante pacto
histórico y hernán cadavid representante
a la cámara por el partido centro
democrático de oposición gracias a
nuestros invitados y a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de esta conversación dejen
sus preguntas y sus comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
twitter instagram y facebook en donde no
se encuentran como france24
ese ángel ago efe 24 mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
y en youtube también pueden seguir
nuestra señal en streaming además
saludamos a las personas que nos
escuchan en nuestro podcast no olviden
que todos nuestros contenidos los pueden
encontrar disponibles en app el podcast
spotify deezer y también en junín para
entrar en materia vamos a recordar el
pronunciamiento de lln sobre un posible
cese de hostilidades
nosotros partimos de un hecho hay que
construir sobre lo construido
sino solución o hacer una ronda de
diálogo bajo el cese bilateral pues vale
la pena repetir experiencia porque fue
algo positivo y en el marco de esta
noticia hay otro asunto que ha cobrado
relevancia y es la participación del
gobierno venezolano como garante del
proceso que se confirmó esta semana
escuchemos
y le estoy diciendo al presidente
gustavo petro ya colombia que una vez
más como lo hizo el comandante chávez
en su tiempo para garantizar los
acuerdos de paz que luego se firmaron y
que me tocó participar como garantes una
vez más presidente gustavo petro y a
colombia le decimos venezuela acepta el
carácter de garantes de las
negociaciones y de los acuerdos de paz
de colombia con el ln y pondremos
nuestra mejor voluntad en nombre de dios
padre todopoderoso por la paz total de
colombia y vamos a comenzar con las
preguntas primero quisiera la opinión de
iván cepeda que habla por la parte del
gobierno y bueno gracias a ustedes por
estar con nosotros y empecemos por
venezuela precisamente la retoma del
contacto y de las relaciones con el
gobierno de nicolás maduro han sido
objeto de críticas de la oposición del
país porque entonces elegir precisamente
a ese país como garante de un eventual
proceso con lln
gracias angela y un saludo al
representante cadavid bueno en realidad
no es una designación nueva el el
gobierno de venezuela ha fungido como
garante del proceso de paz con lln y
también lo hizo en su momento con las
farc en distintos momentos
y su acompañamiento
y ayuda al proceso
contribuyó en el caso de las farc al
firmar el acuerdo de 2016 y en el caso
de lln contribuyó en la fase
exploratoria de el proceso que se truncó
bajo el gobierno del expresidente duque
al llegar a una agenda y avanzar en esas
conversaciones así que
independientemente de las valoraciones
que tengamos de el sistema político en
venezuela y las contradicciones que hay
hoy en ese país para efectos de la paz
de colombia esa contribución ha sido una
contribución eficaz que ha permitido
avanzar en este campo y la misma
pregunta quisiera entregarla a hernán
cadavid el representante de la cámara
por el partido centro democrático hernán
lo escuchamos
bueno angela un saludo gracias por esta
invitación al escenario and 7a también
un saludo mire yo creo que es un gran
error el planteamiento lo que se hace en
este momento del inicio del diálogo con
lg g es esta fin nosotros estamos de
acuerdo la la paz se necesita nosotros
no estamos en desacuerdo con ese
planteamiento pero estos procesos
necesitan la dignidad del pueblo propia
y en colombia hay un gran rechazo por
entrar gente venezuela
responsable el que mate es el punto 5
millones de personas está incorporada su
país del 61.8 en colombia así podemos
evidenciar lo que por consecuencia
política han sufrido esas personas y no
se entiende como entonces un mandatario
servil ha señalado o no reconocido en
muchos países del mundo de al lado como
violados derechas trans es ahorita el
sig mango que jugará ante el proceso de
paz que no logra estabilizar su país
tiene grandes señalamientos por maltrato
de derechos humanos iván relación a los
derechos humanos y ahora nos dice que la
cuota inicial del producto de diálogos
con el bng es ponernos en forma para
duro como para acceder si estos son los
caminos angela y tele es que dan de que
no va a haber mucho apoyo popular a un
proceso de extracción que se puede
necesitar pero no es usted bueno sin
embargo yo quisiera mencionarle hernán
un escenario y es que una realidad es
que el l n opera ampliamente en la
frontera con venezuela
pese a todo aquí le pregunto era
inevitable invitar a venezuela a
participar en la solución de un
conflicto que finalmente afecta a sus
fronteras que finalmente afecta a dos
países que son vecinos y bueno pues se
declaró también aclararles a nuestros
televidentes que fue el propio gustavo
petro quien envió la carta de invitación
a nicolás maduro para que se uniera pues
a este proceso como garante
por supuesto que es necesario tener en
cuenta a países vecinos no solamente a
venezuela también ecuador en los sitios
de fronteras también hay presencia de
grupos ilegales en caso de rl uno de los
grandes problemas que tienen de él es
que no tiene una unidad de mando que es
un poco de impago que podía suceder con
las farc y no se sabe con quién se va a
negociar y con el comando central que
está en cuba o por los comandantes de
los bloques que están operando en
colombia alguna diferencia fundamental
con lo que sucedía con las farc pero
para responder las preguntas una cosa es
tener 50 íbamos a los mandatarios o
gobiernos vecinos y otra muy distinta es
darle la caritat era garante de paz y un
protagonismo internacional que como lo
repito no es porque lo que es un partido
de oposición en colombia lo que damos
nosotros es porque en gran parte del
mundo el régimen de maduro en señalar
los derechos humanos y ahora lo que con
internacionalmente lo elevamos
internacionalmente le damos una
articulación
mandatario que está altamente
cuestionado senador cepeda se quisiera
hacer alguna réplica
si
llevamos
cuatro años de suspensión de los
diálogos con el l en el anterior
gobierno del ex presidente iván duque
decidió romper con esas conversaciones
e igualmente decidió romper toda
relación con venezuela
no solamente de índole política y
diplomática sino también
comercial y allí están pues en los
resultados de esa política lln se ha
fortalecido es un hecho hoy está
presente en más territorios hoy tiene
más integrantes y tiene más capacidad de
daño
y la ausencia de relaciones con
venezuela se tradujo en una agudización
de los problemas en la frontera la
frontera entre colombia y venezuela que
es una frontera pues de una gran
extensión es uno de los lugares con más
violencia en el territorio nacional
entonces definitivamente la política del
aislacionismo
y de la ruptura de la búsqueda de la paz
no ha conducido a nada bueno
podemos hacer una discusión amplia tal
vez en otro programa sobre la naturaleza
del sistema político y del régimen en
venezuela pero para efectos de la paz
que es lo que en este caso interesa la
participación de venezuela ha mostrado
los reitero un efecto benéfico se logró
un acuerdo de paz con farc en parte
precisamente por esa participación bueno
lo cierto aquí y respetando cada una de
las posturas es que se está intentando
una fórmula distinta a la que se intentó
en los últimos gobiernos que tuvo
colombia y aquí pasó mi siguiente
pregunta y es que pablo beltrán quien
encabeza la delegación es de él en
cuba'' dijo que él y que otros delegados
en la habana desde que fracasaron las
conversaciones en 2019 podrían regresar
al país en las próximas semanas que se
sabe de las garantías de seguridad que
les ofrecerá el gobierno y las
condiciones actuales pregunto son las
correctas para sentarse a discutir una
eventual desmovilización y quisiera
comenzar esta pregunta con el
representante del centro democrático
ang la le contesto pero próximamente no
es sin dejar de mencionar de residente y
es que esto es cierto que el gobierno
anterior rompió las conversaciones con
el leer es importante decir que fue
posterior a un ataque terrorista en el
infarto en plena negociación
contra una escuela de la policía donde
fallecieron 22 cabezas no tenían ni
siquiera la condición de combatientes
murieron 22 jovencitas esa fue la causa
de la ruptura desde ese entonces están
refugiados en pudo y si están dadas las
condiciones
para que yo retornen al territorio
colombiano pues nos tendrá que contestar
el gobierno actual en la medida que no
es sobre el eje que ha crecido y se ha
expandido sobre una base
fundamentalmente el narcotráfico sino
que hay otros cinco los tres grupos que
han generado gran violencia y que siguen
captando territorio en el país pero que
además ha manifestado en esa ansiedad
que ha planteado ver no quiere negociar
con todos estos grupos
en el crédito con bandas criminales
inclusive rechazó el mecanismo del
proyecto de ley de orden público que ha
defendido el senador se fea y que tiene
vacíos de mi opinión y lln dice que este
no es un mecanismo sólido por tanto
ellos serán los que tengan que responder
si se sienten en condiciones de volver y
el gobierno decirles si tiene las
condiciones para protegerlas
senador cepeda su respuesta
bueno nosotros creemos firmemente en la
posibilidad de superar el conflicto
armado mediante un diálogo y mediante un
acuerdo de paz es cierto en estos
procesos siempre hay momentos muy
difíciles lastimosamente la
confrontación armada en colombia trae
hechos que son absolutamente excesivos
pero la única manera de acabar con ellos
es precisamente ponerle punto final a
esa confrontación que lleva ya más de
seis décadas en colombia así que la
política de guerra sin cuartel y repito
a lo único que ha traído es a más
violencia en colombia a que se pluraliza
en los grupos y se multipliquen en los
territorios y el gobierno que ha
entregado la pasada administración del
país que ha entregado la pasada
administración es un país sembrado de
violencia porque no tuvo una política de
paz porque renunció a implementar
debidamente el acuerdo que se suscribió
en 2016 con la guerrilla de las farc y
porque no hizo a diferencia de otros
gobiernos tal vez es el primer gol en
los últimos 40 años que no hizo un solo
esfuerzo para buscar la paz en el país
en todo caso senador cepeda hay
incertidumbre generada por el hecho de
que pueda producirse un nuevo alto el
fuego y que esté alto el fuego se
respete se cumpla y que lleve
efectivamente un avance en unas nuevas
conversaciones el alto al fuego anterior
sucedió alrededor desde el año 2017 y
beltrán él lo ha calificado como un
momento que fue positivo y que por lo
tanto tendría que repetirse y pues para
allá vamos como se están planteando las
cosas con el gobierno de gustavo petro
usted qué opina fue positivo lo que
sucedió en 2017
en 2017 vivimos dos meses en los cuales
decrecieron de una manera
pues muy significativa los atentados y
acciones militares del ejército de
liberación nacional y bajaron los
índices de violencia en el país así que
creo que el alto al fuego es una fórmula
para avanzar en el proceso de paz que
ofrece un alivio a la situación de
comunidades que se encuentran hoy en
medio del conflicto armado este no es un
problema simplemente de una táctica de
negociación es un problema de garantizar
la vida de muchas poblaciones que están
hoy repito en medio del fuego y de la
confrontación militar
y su opinión por favor hernán cadavid
mire anglada preocupaciones cuál es si
colombia tuviera solamente el desafío
del e-learning frente no diría puede ser
el digamos conducente un cese al fuerte
pero lo acaba de mencionar yo creo que
hay estimaciones entre 5 y 6 conflictos
con grupos en colombia entre ellos un
gran grupo de las disidencias de las
farc de miembros que estuvieron y
recibieron todas las garantías en la
negociación que se suscribió en 2016 y
que muchos de sus cabecillas luego
reincidieron en el narcotráfico el
senado se esperan sabe que eso es así
que muchos de ellos se asentaron en
venezuela hoy están constituidos como un
gran grupo las disidencias de las farc
luego está el clan del golfo grupo de
internet o tráfico a la extorsión a la
minería ilegal
los llamados caparrós está por supuesto
lln por tanto cuando se ha hablado de un
cese bilateral o multilateral si eso
implica también la parálisis del estado
en la ley el accionar de la fuerza
pública pues basta preocupar porque
estaríamos dejando de actuar también
sobre grupos y no están en el marco de
una negociación y que no podrían estar
en el marco de una negociación en
términos cómo se quiere adelantar con el
lg por tanto yo sí aprovecho este medio
para decirle al gobierno ya la bancada
del gobierno en qué consiste el llamado
cese multilateral porque si eso implica
la parálisis de la acción de la fuerza
pública contra todos los grupos al
margen de la ley en colombia le
estaríamos dando vía libre al delito en
este país y creo que eso tendrá un gran
error yo estructural para lo que hay una
futura representante y no le parece que
ahí también hay que tener en cuenta la
expectativa que existe con otros grupos
ilegales durante el primer mes de la
presidencia de gustavo petro que se
acaba de cumplir en el hizo
declaraciones en las que afirmó que ha
recibido cartas de otros grupos que
también podrían estar dispuestos a
negociar no cree que ésta también podría
ser una oportunidad digamos para
englobar estos conflictos y abrir esta
nueva fórmula también para ellos
angela es el mismo en
manifestaciones públicas que no se
quieren ir en globo para utilizar sus
términos en una negociación conjunta
además porque los grupos tienen
connotaciones políticas o jurídicas
distintas no se puede negociar
minoritario donde los términos a una
banda criminal de eta simplemente al
delito arrancó tráfico que es en mi
opinión lo que está haciendo en el eje
también en la práctica pero se le va a
dar seguramente más conmutación política
para porque ellos no van a dejarse
desnivelar de los términos en que fueron
tratadas lanzan a términos políticos por
tanto son ellos mil los que se están
excluyendo de esa misma vida y lo
segundo es que siento una gran ansiedad
por parte del gobierno nacional de
tratar de resolver estos temas con estos
grupos al margen de la ley de manera
inmediata y eso puede estar les en su
método del pie y procede grifos y con el
uno con el otro
el isis
este no es un vaticinio mi propio quiera
que las cosas salgan mal son los mismos
grupos al margen de la ley especialmente
dentro cuando estamos hablando del que
ha dicho a mí no me vaya a atentar con
bandas criminales que si somos lo mismo
y nos van a tratar igual por tanto creo
que el gobierno del pp un gran problema
en online no le anunciado al país cuáles
son los términos que trataría con buzz y
cómo señor se queda usted qué opina de
este asunto porque lo que sí puede ser
cierto y podemos estar de acuerdo los
tres es que es una gran apuesta la que
está haciendo el gobierno petro y pues
una gran apuesta implica también
grandísimos riesgos y como tiene
oportunidades de ser exitosa pues
también tiene todas las oportunidades de
fracasar de esto usted como una puerta
hacia negociaciones gracia búsqueda de
zapata con otros grupos ilegales
angela es que estamos en el fracaso es
decir cada día están matando en colombia
a un líder social estamos viendo
masacres en todo el país y el país está
cansado de la guerra
así que esa vía está
agotada es la vida del fracaso y hay que
trabajar en la paz y si
el representante cada vez dice que
estamos ansiosos por trabajar por la paz
tiene razón porque perdimos cuatro años
en los que no se hizo un solo esfuerzo
por acabar el conflicto armado y repito
aquí están los resultados que él mismo
describe claramente tenemos cinco o seis
confrontaciones que son gravísimas en
colombia hoy y que no existían hace
cuatro años así que es necesario
definitivamente una política como la que
hemos planteado que no es mezclar todo
con todo no es meter y englobar al ln
con las bandas del narcotráfico
a unos grupos que tienen naturaleza
política o que tienen una origen
político de su alzamiento armado se
propone una negociación a otros un
acogimiento a la justicia son dos vías
claramente diferenciadas ahora qué ln y
esos otros grupos tengan que ver con el
narcotráfico pues lo que aquí habría que
decir es que el narcotráfico permea a
toda la nación incluyendo al propio
estado el estado está corroído por la
corrupción y por el narcotráfico así que
este es un problema que tenemos que
resolver también de manera global con un
tratamiento distinto al que ha sido el
de la guerra tradicional contra las
drogas ilícitas que también ha arrojado
como resultado un inmenso fracaso
bueno y ahora para evaluar la situación
lo que sucede por ejemplo en el norte
del país donde hay presencia de varios
grupos criminales entre ellos lln entre
ellos el clan del golfo pues tenemos que
hablar necesariamente de un tema
histórico y es esa necesidad urgente de
atender las regiones rurales olvidadas
culturalmente desprotegidas sin control
del estado en donde hay total espacio
para la delincuencia y para los crímenes
y para las violaciones a los derechos
humanos y de hecho hay una gran crisis
en el norte del país en este momento por
esas violaciones y por las amenazas y
asesinatos de líderes y lideresas
sociales uces en fuego de fuego senador
cepeda podría facilitar una llegada del
estado a estas zonas que además está por
supuesto entre las grandes promesas de
gustavo petro y ese pues lo dijeron en
el día de la posición del gobierno de
los nadies
sí yo creo que es ahí donde radica el
problema
y esa es la invitación que le hago al
representante cadavid ya la oposición a
que más allá de estas discusiones sobre
cómo se lleva a cabo una negociación de
paz hablemos sobre cómo resolvemos la
pobreza endémica que hay en los
territorios en colombia' de poblaciones
que están sumidas en el atraso
rodeadas de una naturaleza exuberante
pero que no tienen posibilidades de
cultivar
en productos agrícolas alimentos para
resolver la situación tanto de esas
comunidades como del país es un absurdo
que en colombia haya pobreza en las
zonas rurales con semejante riqueza
natural y ese sí es un problema que
debiéramos intentar resolver de manera
mancomunada quienes estamos en el
gobierno y también en la oposición
porque es la raíz histórica del
conflicto armado colombiano y de la
violencia y del propio narcotráfico
claro pero también entiendo ahora al
representante de la cámara y me pongo en
sus zapatos para que me dé usted su
visión sobre esta pregunta y es que
también hay quienes dirían que usted es
el fuego pues es una oportunidad para
que vuelva a la delincuencia aún con más
fuerza con mucho menos control del poco
que tal vez ya se estaba ejerciendo
usted usted qué opina
mire lo primero es que el ante las
palabras del senador no puede quedar
planteado como si éste a nosotros no nos
importara resolver los problemas de
pobreza en este país
permitir que la medida que hay una
inversión razonable importante pues a la
vez eso se refleja en una política
social que permita a sacar a las
personas de la pobreza yo creo que todos
buscamos lo mismo tal vez habrá muchas
diferencias en las formas pero estamos
en el mismo propósito y no hay digamos
una esquina que quiera dejar a una gente
en la pobreza y otra de la ciudad exacta
pero para ir a su lugar su pregunta
puntualmente angela es si digamos y
mucho se dice es que el gobierno no pero
el gobierno no cumplió primero hay
varias cosas
y lo que no se ha revisado es que los
planteamientos que le hicieron al país
sobre la base todos los mecanismos del
acuerdo algo van a funcionar pero otros
fracasaron cenamos
etb1 funcionaron y otros lo defraudaron
como sucedió con los graves y gas que
inclusive desde harm esperando al ex
presentarse a la curul ustedes tuvieron
todas las condiciones a un hombre como
iván márquez y hoy que está sucediendo
cuando el marqués es un cabecilla de la
disidencia del ipad que le faltó a iván
márquez tenía todas las condiciones de
seguridad toda la estabilidad política
todas las garantías para acceder a nacer
como lo estaba haciendo en otros más
pero tengo reparos que ballesta y
entonces ahorita no para entrar decirlo
y otra vez iván márquez cabecilla perdón
a un lado de los años 80-90 se conocen
porque en esa historia perdonado detrás
de la puerta estaban a se conoce
perfectamente bien sexo ya puede venir
defrauda puede a lanzar más ahorita van
a abrirle la puerta nueva aquí
interesado en dos ocasiones- acuerdos de
paz es la responsabilidad no es
solamente separando gobiernos sin
importar el nombre sino también la
responsabilidad de quienes han utilizado
las armas y responde mails señor cada
vida en ese sentido que tanto se está
jugando desde la oposición en su punto
de vista gustavo petro su capital
político con estos diálogos mientras que
busca cumplir esta promesa grandísima de
paz total en colombia además de este
nuevo diálogo pues que estará
inevitablemente vinculado a su promesa
de implementar en su totalidad los
acuerdos de paz con la ex guerrilla de
las farc que se efectuarán en 2016 y por
los cuales también ha habido muchísimos
roces con su partido y acusaciones de
que no se implementaron que no se hizo
una acción adecuada con estos acuerdos y
este caminar hacia la paz que se anunció
en el 2016
bueno angela cuando se le pregunta
muchos de los desmovilizados al propio
gobierno si se ha cumplido si se han
establecido como lo decía arriba
seguramente por margen de error como
todos los consejeros de la
inhabilitación por lo que alinea
asistiendo a proyectos de movilizaciones
desde los años 90 el event 19 el cual
hace parte hizo parte de es pago pero el
presidente de la república el fm todo en
su mensaje en 90 fnm también lo hizo
parcialmente sfar 7 ellos aducen por
tanto esto es un proceso que el país
tendría que aprender a corregir cada vez
que se intente hacer lo que no nos
pueden decir es que mire al noticias
desde el estar bien 90 como si fueran la
foto de hoy rl en esa próxima
negociación y cada vez van ganando más
expansión más tiempo este reproche de
nosotros nuestro que no queramos ir
hacia un ambiente
este es el de hostilidades en parís o de
tercera violencia para el suplente por
externo si no es por regir los amigos
para que esto no se convierta en un
círculo vicioso en donde utilizan la
tarde se reutilizan acceden al poder
político impuestos de nuestros tres años
están volviendo a delinquir no eres una
opinión rica sobran son los hechos y
aristas demostrados con cabecillas como
sampling iván márquez y tantos otros más
estuvieron en la habana con usted
senador cepeda y luego retornaron a la
violencia y usted sabe que eso pasó
senador cepeda la misma pregunta que
tanto se está jugando a gustavo petro su
capital político con estas apuestas que
está haciendo por la paz total sobre
todo después de que se han conocido ya
en el país o como quedan conformados los
partidos cuales se alinean con el
gobierno cuales se alinean con la
oposición y pues claro en este momento
la presidencia digamos tiene o goza de
una mayoría también en el legislativo
pero pues esto puede cambiar en
cualquier momento si no se cumplen todas
estas expectativas
con trabajar por la paz es un imperativo
ético no es un cálculo político
y fracasar buscando la paz creo que es
noble creo que hay que hacer la apuesta
que se está haciendo en nosotros no
hemos sostenido que el centro
democrático no quiera encontrarle una
solución al conflicto que esté por la
pobreza en las zonas rurales lo que
hacemos es una invitación a discutir
realmente sus temas el problema no
radica en que se haya implementado
excesivamente el acuerdo de paz de 2016
no se hizo la reforma agraria está
prevista en ese acuerdo no se resolvió
por la vía de la sustitución de cultivos
la situación de centenares de miles de
campesinos que siembran hoy coca en
colombia así que el acuerdo no se ha
implementado debidamente y en eso tienen
responsabilidad quienes han tenido
funciones de gobierno así que en este
gobierno vamos a buscar la
implementación la implementación plena
integral
y mediante esa implementación evitar que
sigan ocurriendo en muchas zonas del
país
decepciones a la paz o reproducción de
grupos armados ilegales es en las
condiciones en las que no hay una
política social en las que la única
solución es hacer que haga presencia
pues las instituciones militares el
ejército y que se incentive la violencia
y no responder al problema de los
jóvenes en las zonas rurales de las
poblaciones que vienen en la miseria que
pues se encuentra su caldo de cultivo el
recrudecimiento del conflicto armado y
ese es el problema que invitamos a
dialogar y encontrarle solución a todas
las fuerzas políticas del país
senador cepeda cuáles son las líneas
rojas del gobierno colombiano para
evitar otro escenario por ejemplo de
disidencias qué es lo que estamos
viviendo hoy o de un fracaso total como
pasó en los 90 con la sed en la zona de
distensión del cagüán pues aquí se trata
también de aprender las lecciones del
pasado
las líneas rojas consisten en o la
principal línea roja es que si el estado
se compromete a llevar a cabo unos
cambios en un acuerdo de paz no puede
dejar de cumplirlos es la palabra del
estado la que está empeñada y solamente
cuando se cumplen los acuerdos de paz
cuando se realizan las transformaciones
sociales se podrá tener éxito en este
camino y aquí no es simplemente una una
cuestión de quién tiene más fortaleza en
una mesa de conversaciones sino si el
estado puede responder en solucionar los
problemas sociales y económicos de la
población bien y representante cada
vídeo ustedes como oposición pues tienen
todo el derecho y además tienen la
obligación de en cierta manera
fiscalizar lo que va a suceder porque
esto está sucediendo se está anunciando
y se están moviendo las cosas muy
rápidamente ni siquiera hemos llegado a
dos meses del gobierno de gustavo petro
y ya estamos hablando de retomar
diálogos no sólo con lln sino también
con otros grupos delincuenciales cuáles
son esas líneas rojas que ustedes se
establecen para ejercer su labor como
oposición
a mí la lo primero por decir es que aquí
todos los gestos y los apellidos del
gobierno sin ninguna respuesta por parte
del l no habían pasado siete días de la
posición del presidente pero cuando ya
estaba un avión una fuga creo además que
con la presencia del senador setter ya
habría orden del ámbito de órdenes de
captura y extradición
todos éstos han sido descubiertos
ninguno se ha recibido desde por lo
menos uno lo conocen y lo ha recibido el
país y la primera línea rojenses en la
condescendencia total no sea por parte
de la institucionalidad mientras los
grupos armados navegan avanzan a sus
anchas y los segundos por supuesto es
que nosotros no estaríamos de acuerdo y
que se web a amigos de la
institucionalidad en que la vía armada
permita operar como consecuencia final
en acceso al poder político vive sin
haber pasado por la justicia a una
sanción como sucede con las farc bones
para 7 a 20 sanciones para los pedidos
públicas yo creo que tiene equivalencia
de lo contrario para el país será muy
duro entender que la vía para acceder al
poder político son las armas mientras
que los ciudadanos de bien se tiene el
peso tienen que quedar conformes con lo
que valgo entiendo lo que pasa al frente
esas no puedes ese no puede ser el
círculo vicioso en que metan a colombia
porque lo vamos a terminar esto un
incentivo perverso para que en los
próximos 4 ó 5 años ya sea otro grupo el
que diga también me siento pero me dan
el poder político muy bien estamos
llegando ya al final de este programa y
vamos a dar paso a las conclusiones
antes y muy rápidamente el senador
cepeda le quiero preguntar usted estuvo
en la delegación que visitó cuba para
cuando podríamos tener una noticia del
inicio de los diálogos
esperamos que sea lo más pronto posible
y no es cierto que no estén existiendo
contraprestaciones lln ha dejado varias
personas que tenían su poder en estos en
este mes y ha comenzado a trabajar
seriamente para poder reiniciar las
conversaciones
creo que eso es mucho más de lo que
puede decir el gobierno o lo que pudo
decir el gobierno del expresidente
eduque repito bajo cuyo mandato lln se
fortaleció y adquirió más capacidad de
destrucción
muy bien me queda claro y ahora pues el
señor cada vez por favor en su
conclusión en negociaciones con lll si
no y por qué no puesto nosotros tenemos
siempre apertura y la hemos tendido a
que exista sociales dos pero no con una
concesión total por parte del estado
intenso nosotros estaremos vigilantes
denunciantes ante la comunidad
internacional y con el ánimo de que se
corrijan y los planteamientos entonces
para demorar unos nuevos fracasos esa es
nuestra intención
y por supuesto que en este país todos
tenemos la paz es un discurso exclusivo
del
señor se queda ya para el cierre me
queda dividiendo la respuesta del cuando
y por favor sus conclusiones
cuando lo más pronto posible no tengo no
le podría dar una fecha pero espero que
sea muy pronto y mi conclusión es que el
único fracaso posible en colombia es
seguir insistiendo en una vía que ha
llevado a 60 años de conflicto armado y
a 10 millones de víctimas
como resultado de la confrontación
armada la única vía para resolver esa
situación histórica es la paz y la
búsqueda de la negociación obviamente
con dignidad y con severidad también
cuando se requiere pero buscando que esa
sea la vía principal pues gracias a los
dos por estar en el debate de france 24
este es un tema al que le queda
muchísima tela por cortar sobre todo
mucho gobierno por transcurrir así que
lo cierto es que aquí hay una nueva
fórmula que se está probando y estaremos
aquí para reportar cómo se desarrolla
muchas gracias de también a nuestros
televidentes por estar una vez más con
nosotros y sigan en france24
[Música]